Remember in the beginning of this lesson, we asked you
to think about your favorite app? Mine was Google Now. So
take a moment and play with that, your favorite application. And
take into account all the stuff you learned in lesson one.
And then go to the forum, and share with everyone why
you love this application. So take the time to think about
whether the things you love are visual or non-visual. Whether they're
UI or UX related. So as developers, this is going to
be an awesome opportunity for you to share your design opinions.
>> And if you see someone else, bad mouthing an application that you're
passionate about, take this as a opportunity
to understand that there's many, many different
types of users out there. And, and really get an understanding of how different
people feel about applications, and we'll pick up on this in less than two.